okay let's jump into audience questions
for the week the first
is hey david how likely is violence
after the november election
so there's a few different aspects to
this question the
you're not clarifying violence against
or by which group and i think there's a
few different scenarios that could lead
to violence now
the the most likely scenario that leads
to violence
is trump claims it was rigged
and his supporters take to the streets
with guns
that would be the top like red alert
violence possibility
in my mind um are there scenarios
in which so you know there are right
wingers
who seem to be suggesting that if trump
gets re-elected
the left is going to become so
out of control furious that the left
will start
rioting and burning things to the ground
and
looting and and and all of this stuff um
i that's not really what i'm afraid of i
think that if donald trump
were to get reelected there will be
it'll sort of be a 50 50 effect
some people much like when trump was
first elected in november of 2016
will be outraged and will take to the
streets and
as you remember from november of 2016
those were widely peaceful protests
november december 26th i don't even
remember
uh incidents um
you know nationwide protests hundreds
and hundreds of thousands of people
protesting and
you know you could probably find some
news story of some anecdote but it was
not part of the narrative very different
than
the narrative that the wright created
around the george floyd protest so some
people on the left certainly if trump is
reelected they will be out there
protesting
but there's also going to be a lot of
people on the left who are just totally
deflated and i expect
a portion of the left will check out of
politics for maybe not four years but
certainly until the 2022 midterm
and then we'll get involved in the 2024
election relatively late because it will
be i mean listen i i understand i've
said before
um trump is better for my business but
he's terrible for the country and so i
am fine with my business not doing as
well
if it's good for the country but if it's
another four years of trump
it is go i'm going to certainly be
deflated and i know there are lots of
people on the left who will be as well
and i would not be shocked for a bunch
of those people to check out
so i don't believe there's a real risk
of violence if trump
wins now if trump loses there's a couple
different scenarios
there's trump loses by an insane margin
like electorally
it's a huge margin and popular vote i
don't think that the right is likely
to become too violent in that case trump
could claim
it's obviously rigged because i never
would have lost by this much but i think
the truth is that if both the popular
vote and the electoral vote are big
margins for biden
i think that by and large the trumpists
will just say wow we just lost and they
will
essentially disappear for some period of
time i don't think they're likely to be
violent in that case
i think the two scenarios for violence
would be
big popular vote win but it's
really tight electorally and trump loses
by just like one or two states
and claims it's rigged i think that
scenario could certainly lead to
violence and then i think the one that
is
most likely to lead to trumpists out in
the streets is that everything is close
and trump loses
uh both electorally and popular vote and
says it was rigged and that's the one
where i would worry about you know the
so-called gun
people that donald trump has referred to
going out there
and doing some uh some some horrible
things
i believe it will be relatively
short-lived
um if and when it becomes clear that
trump just lost and no secretary of
state is going to
save him and that even if he could
file some lawsuit to get a recount or
even flip one state that that it won't
be enough
in the scenario where it's a bigger
victory for joe biden if indeed that
happens
i think that the the violence will be
quelled relatively quickly
and by inauguration time i believe it
will essentially be
over now whether we see more radical
extremists
activated if trump is removed
that's a fair question which i'd have to
think about a little more but i think
that the most likely scenario for
violence
is a trump loss that is not a
major loss that it's close and trump
claims it's rigged
maybe refuses to concede and continues
to argue that either vote by mail went
wrong or something like that that's the
scenario that to me lends itself most
uh to violence in the streets and i hope
that
authorities will be ready and prepared
to deal with that